Tyler is with us in Orlando hi Tyler how
are you good how are you better than I
deserve man what's up alright so I am 22
newly married and I am about seven
thousand dollars in credit card debts
between me and my wife and we are trying
to money starting to get a little tight
between all these debts and we're trying
to figure out a way to get it taken care
of as soon as possible through the help
of a friend I've started using the every
dollar app and started creating a budget
for myself and it's pretty shocking to
see how little extra money I have every
month and one thing that I was the main
question I'm asking is my dad and my
stepmom they recently did a debt
consolidation to take care of all of
their credit card debt that they had a
little bit more than I and they were
advising that it's something I should
consider because of how it cut down the
monthly and all their debt and had to go
into one place and I got to paid off a
lot quicker but I was was curious if
that was something that would be advised
either to do or against well it kind of
sweeps it under the rug is what it does
it keeps you in debt longer and and you
know because there's only one way that
that payment goes down and that's if you
extend the length of the term because
you're not going to reduce the interest
rate substantially with a debt
consolidation loan and so it's it's kind
of an illusion is what it is what is
your income between me and my wife it's
about 40,000 mm-hmm and what other debt
other than the 7,000 do you have we have
two newer vehicles what do you own your
cars between the both each one each one
about 35 and $38,000 yes sir
and you make 40,000 yes sir I think we
found the problem your cars are insane
dude absolutely completely nuts
nowhere no wonder you can't breathe man
you have caught you have $70,000 where
the cars you make 40,000 you know what
that means that means you have about six
times as much to in vehicles as you need
I mean like way out there in outer space
yeah so uh I can think I can help you
you need to sell both cars immediately
and so even if I did that I mean I'd
obviously go upside down quite a bit so
I mean how would I take care of that
dude you're so broke you can't breathe
well you got you got $1,200 in car
payments um
we're almost at 1100 yeah dadgum man
it's unbelievable
yeah so even if you did that I mean even
if you did that dude you have to do that
you're gonna go bankrupt you're not
gonna make it
these cars are they're pounding your
face in you have got to get rid of them
like acid is in your dadgum hair man I
mean you got to go nuts here so yeah
you're gonna have to borrow the
difference or whatever you've got to do
to get them sold you're probably upside
down in both of them but I would rather
you be $10,000 in debt than $70,000 in
debt and driving to burgers you'd get
your life back right yeah you know I'll
walk out in the driveway and don't don't
get a spray can in your hand for real
but in your mind I want you to spray
paint across the side of those cars
brain damage because that's what they
represent dude it's absolutely nuts you
are that's your problem
paint your seven thousand dollars in
credit card debt or a debt consolidation
on that that's a one on a scale of 1 to
10 this is a 15 on a scale of 1 to 10
you need to go nuclear on these cars and
get rid of them
that's your only shot I don't know if
you'll do it or not but that's what you
should do if you don't in three years
you're going to call me talking about
the repos that you had and how you had
to go bankrupt early in your marriage
and I hope I don't get that call from
you I'll help you either way
but I want you to be smart not stupid
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the
out you can do this you know that really
is a message whether you've got two
hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or twenty seven
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar income
[Music]